Speaker 1: So I'm really depressed about what's
going on in Pennsylvania.
As many of you know, we've been following
the Pennsylvania Senate race as I'll show
you in a moment.
The control of the U.S. Senate after November,
after the midterm elections could depend on
who wins in Pennsylvania because of a number
of different dynamics and realities about
who's up for reelection and where are their
open seats and this type of thing.
So we're very interested in who's going to
be the next senator from Pennsylvania on the
Democratic side.
I have been leaning very heavily not that
I vote in Pennsylvania, but as an opinion.
I've been leaning heavily towards John Fetterman,
the lieutenant governor.
And on the Republican side, the story has
been that television, Dr. Mehmet Oz is running
as a Republican and he has some celebrity.
Donald Trump has endorsed him, etc..
Well, last night there was a Democratic primary
debate and a Republican primary debate, and
I found both debates extraordinarily depressing.
We're going to look at some clips of the Republican
part.
I wasn't able to find clips of the Democratic
side, but I watched it yesterday.
And.
It was just really depressing.
So Fetterman, whose policies I like, seemed
disoriented, confused.
He was slow to respond.
He didn't make any sense.
It it was a terrible performance where when
I watched the Republican debate, my thought
was any of the five candidates running on
the Republican side would do well against
Fetterman.
So while I like Fetterman on policy, his debate
performance was terrible in terms of the other
candidates on the Democratic side.
There was a woman, Carly Carlisle, I believe
her last name was, and then a younger guy
named Malcolm Kenyatta and then Conor LAMB.
Kenyatta had some good answers, but at one
point simply said no.
When asked whether he wants to answer a question,
he said no.
And it was bizarre.
And then Conor LAMB, clearly the most polished
in terms of media preparation, but a very
uninspiring kind of center left establishment
Democrat.
It wasn't like, wow, one of these people would
crush a debate against these Republicans.
So that was on the Democratic side.
It wasn't thrilling, to say the least.
On the Republican side, it was straight up
sinister disinformation.
I mean, just absolutely crazy.
And we're going to look at a couple of clips.
First of all, the debate opened with an argument
over who's really from Pennsylvania based
on how long they've been in Pennsylvania.
Here's a little bit of that.
Speaker 6: 70% of Republican voters said the
amount of time a candidate has lived in Pennsylvania
is important.
We begin with Mr. McCormack.
You've been campaigning on your Pennsylvania
roots, but you have not actually lived in
Pennsylvania for the last 15 years.
So explain why it seems that you return to
the Commonwealth just in time to run for the
US Senate.
Mr..
MCCORMACK You have 60 seconds to Mr. Oz except
for your time attending medical school and
graduate school.
You have not actually lived in the Commonwealth
in Pennsylvania.
So how do you respond to concerns that you
do not know what is best for Pennsylvanians?
You have 60 seconds, sir.
Speaker 1: So so the first question everybody
just talked about how long they had been in
Pennsylvania.
Okay.
I mean, yes, the voters claimed they care
about it, but it's already not actually substantive.
Then there was the Trump sucking up portion
of the entire thing where Trump endorsed Dr.
Oz.
And so Dr. Oz, in basically every answer,
would mention that.
But every candidate tried to suck up to Trump.
That was the next section.
Speaker 2: He went groveling to President
Trump.
President Trump saw right through and did
not endorse.
And then he endorsed me.
Speaker 6: Everything President Trump put
in place worked.
Speaker 2: A reason Mama keeps talking about
President Trump's endorsement is because he
can't run on his own positions.
President Trump won Pennsylvania and President
Trump endorsed being President.
Trump was very clear of America first.
Speaker 6: I'm the only person in this race
that was appointed by President Trump.
You say that you are America first.
You did so much for President Trump and yet
he rejected.
Speaker 2: Thank you, Ms.. Barnett.
Once again, trying to tell Pennsylvanians
something that President Trump does not believe
is true.
Speaker 6: President Trump doesn't always
get the best advice.
How?
I am the only conservative voice.
No, you're not dishonest.
Speaker 2: Dave is at it again.
What President Trump did, he put his finger
on the fact President Trump did was respect
people who had been other forgotten, canceled.
Speaker 6: President Trump coined the word
maga.
Speaker 2: I have discussed with President
Trump and just like President Trump, that
experience is going to make me a better senator.
So much so that President Trump on his tell
a town hall we need to enforce the policies
that worked under the Trump administration.
What President Trump saw right through him.
He therefore did not endorse Mr. McCormick
endorsed me.
President Trump's policies.
Trump was able to put together Operation Warp
Speed we.
Speaker 6: Saw under the Trump economy.
Speaker 1: All right.
So you guys get the picture.
So then it was an hour.
First it was an argument over who's lived
in Pennsylvania the longest and long enough.
Then it was an argument over which of us is
the most liked by Trump.
And most like Trump, the funniest moment from
the entire thing was when Dave McCormick,
who seems to be kind of like the second, you
know, right up there with Mehmet Oz and Barnett,
they seem to be the three frontrunners.
He said there's no miracle cure, which I love
because of Dr. Oz's history as a guy promoting
all sorts of quack cures.
This was this was probably the funniest moment.
Speaker 2: And now he's flip flopping.
And the problem, Doctor, is there's no miracle
cure for flip flopping.
And Pennsylvanians are seeing right through
your phoniness, and that's what you're dealing
with and that's why you're not taking off
in the polls.
Speaker 1: So that's actually great.
I mean, Dr. Oz promoting, you know, drinkable
silver and various quack cures of different
kinds.
So that is actually pretty clever.
But these are all absolutely terrible people.
And unfortunately, I hate to say this, but
if I'm honest, the energy of any of these
five candidates likely would come off better
in a debate against the four Democratic candidates
I saw yesterday.
I hate to say it.
Here is one last clip where candidate Sanders
attacks Candidate Barnett for how how big?
Her margin of loss was in her previous election.
And then they argue over who most believes
in the 2020 big lie in Washington.
Speaker 6: You can count on me.
They did not steal that election by 20 points.
She lost her last election to a weak, weak
Democrat.
John Fetterman is not a weak Democrat.
He's strong.
I will be John Fetterman in the fall.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
I am going to give you 30 seconds to respond.
Speaker 6: Thank you so much for that.
Because are you saying that there was absolutely
that that that the 2020 election was above
par, that there was no fraud, that there was
no issues with that point?
Are you telling me that it was perfect and
if and because apparently that's what she's
saying.
So for all of us in the Republican Party now,
we have a candidate on stage, Carlos san,
who is saying that there was absolutely nothing
to see and that 2020 election.
But beyond that, you know, you say that you
are America first.
You did so much for President Trump and yet
he rejected.
Speaker 2: Thank you for that.
Speaker 6: Because you that and Mr..
Speaker 2: And Ms. hands I'm going give you
15 seconds quickly to respond to that.
Speaker 6: President Trump doesn't always
get the best advice.
Speaker 1: There were actually times where
each candidate was given 10 seconds sometimes
to respond.
I mean, it's the format doesn't work.
The candidates are lunatics.
The topics are absurd.
So it's all very, very depressing now.
Why does Pennsylvania matter so much?
Well, when you look at to 72 wind dot com,
they have a number of different maps that
you can look at.
If you look at the 2022 consensus map, Pennsylvania
is one of only five Senate toss up states.
If you look at Sabato's crystal ball, Pennsylvania's
one of only four toss up states.
If you look at the Cook Political map, Pennsylvania
is one of five toss up states.
And in the political map, it's also one of
five toss up states.
If you run a number of different scenarios
and consider them in a lot of them, Pennsylvania
decides whether Democrats control the Senate
or whether Republicans control the Senate.
And unfortunately, I didn't find any of it
particularly exciting.
Let me know your thoughts if you watched the
debates